jean claude gayssot donc ce n'est pas le
sentiment que vous vivez une aventure
personnelle billets votre compte de fait
est que finalement vous avez un petit
peu oublié que j'avais ouvriers qui ont
été de l'autre côté
non je n'ai rien oublié et et je peux
vous dire que quand on a été non
seulement pauvre comme je l'étais mais
un militant es militant pour la justice
un militant contre les privilèges quels
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs pas simplement
de la fortune mais aussi du pouvoir et
du savoir
eh bien ça s'oublie pas et quand il est
vous arrive cet aspect exceptionnel de
me retrouver ministre ben vous essayez
de
à ce moment là petite échelle de
continuer à ne pas oublier ce que vous
avez été ce que sont des millions des
millions dont merci ont valu merci
beaucoup